[ __ ] uno Rapids does that mean it's good
might be honestly just dance is my
favorite so plunger oh my turn it was
your turn anyway but good job we just
try to keep this nice and calm man we
just try to keep ghosts home I'm called
you don't sound close you can't beat us
like you beat yourself up waiting oh yes
just give me okay and I'll be oh [ __ ]
you let you play no I don't know good
good for me blue I don't have any blue
or so
[Laughter]
listen Bob I don't think those stack
unless you play him one after each other
last the first plus four was legit when
we played the second one he [ __ ]
himself I did didn't I yeah I did yeah I
did the first one was totally fine
ha ha ha ha got you now Bob wait my
camera it's fine ok no no no no hi
whoosh I come back from the dead to [ __ ]
you oh yeah all of you you don't know
that ah ha
let's go have a valid response to pretty
much anything
wait yes okay wait what yeah thank you
computer
I thought was an accident I even I don't
even do that I just laid the zero but I
didn't give you the tool like the dumb
computer just had that card for an hour
knew what it was okay wait listen it's
just a game man it's a game he's used to
only having to play himself and always
winning so if you're your only you I
think God you said that
yeah you laugh rabid I'm with you man
listen man come on man Juan come hey man
hey let's sock let's say listen up man
come on challenger yeah why why would
you do I like blue anyway what challenge
oh no challenges no no no extra no
that's not it no that's a good one Bob's
gonna keep now I'll play this one sorry
Wade well it's great now all right it's
green
[Laughter]
all right listen fools on you now fool
you who's fooled you are I'm just gonna
jump in on myself real hard all right
you just made a great play come on mark
yeah mark yes get your revenge okay all
right here comes here comes big whammo
did you think we have one card before
win yes I did what happened what is that
[ __ ] no is that no no no I don't have
any Reds
no mark that's sketchy sketchy that's
sketchy that's sketchy that scosh [ __ ]
[Music]
that was me that said that before and I
don't appreciate your version of how I
just click I can't I can't not have a
good time just go ahead and get a mark
do your thing
no leave me alone thank you wha well
[ __ ] wait a minute
Oh Bob you'll like it you'll like it
[Laughter]
sucks wait now they could play their
[ __ ] I'll [ __ ] you no it's okay Bob
you keep a train a-rollin I'm just gonna
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
funny right there okay who we are that's
funny no no no yes oh oh I got a couple
snark let's talk about this let's call
everybody calm down what I didn't do
nothing three seconds to play I can't
[ __ ]
it's fine drawing counts apparently
what's he do if I don't play in three
seconds it makes you draw card it's not
that bad I don't have any of those oh
whatever this is I'm playing it oh that
means the next person to draw draws
extra cards oh wait [ __ ] that's not good
that's probably gonna be Wade yellows
looks like guys not red no no I hate all
of you can you get over twenty is it
possible keep it red then huh I don't
have eight oh we've got nines I got nine
red eight I keep getting red [ __ ] aid
[Laughter]
I promise next time I have the option
I'll trade decks with you Oh what is
this head this is worse yeah enjoy that
[Laughter]
no wait let's stop all right what color
did he have I'm pretty sure maybe didn't
have yellow now balls I might be in
trouble with that one that might that
might know what's what's happening wait
can i play oh I think it protects you
from like yeah mother [ __ ] if it was
blue were you gonna win yeah he has blue
left that's just that's just a we gotta
change it mark wild I won't challenge
you Jesus Christ
Oh
[Laughter]
oh boy I got so many good cars over here
uh-huh
Wow mark yes what hello
I believe in the heart of the cards well
okay never mind it kind of worked out oh
it's like a win-win for you can't card
hand in your cards card and now you've
got the best card hand in your cards the
good card hands in your hand cards so
that you've got the good cards in your
hand good Bob you won't trade this hand
back and forth yeah let's do it man
[Laughter]
commuter do it
jiya computer do it I'm trying to work
as a team I can't do it ah yeah hey now
you've got a lot of one card yay good is
what I wanted
all right well that's good I feel good
keep keep it going mark oh you know me I
go just party it up no actually that's
not so bad I think he has to draw oh
wait no I'm I [ __ ] Oh fair well he's
got a red card okay Bob and I change it
from red for God's sake all right all
right
what number see you have mark what
number is that skip right don't cheat
you have a conundrum of cheating and I
just didn't want to betray the cheating
it's a great area win 25 times against
the player under level 20 thanks for
being news guys good stuff thank you
[ __ ] you it's like you hate me it's like
you Amy he's gonna gank you or [ __ ] you
I'm trying to help you figure out which
one you're trying to thank [ __ ] me thank
you
this [ __ ] Thanks [ __ ] everywhere
there's thanks all over your face thank
all over you oh thanks [ __ ] you [ __ ] why
blow again ya know what [ __ ] you
thanks [ __ ] thanks to you [ __ ]
look it's gotta be a PG
thank [ __ ] challenge wait
yeah I know what they have I just saw
funny it's not funny it's got 14 cards
[ __ ] you what do you like this one [ __ ]
you what the casual oh boy yeah I'm just
gonna go ahead and do that well it
wasn't that good anyway
how'd you get so much red enjoy the red
computer I'll take my hand back thank
you it's okay you can play green
probably I could play green or yellow
yelling heart of the cards whatever I
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
was gonna play some [ __ ] you Bob you're
playing you're still here
no you're not you're not in the game
anymore I see all of you why don't
you see me we say blah and blah I just
played a six those are happening okay
goodbye playing - we are playing just
playing oh no I'm just on this long haul
can I come over - you're an obvious play
six could play together you guys want to
play at the same time in the same game
yeah [ __ ] is wrong with you can I
seriously not rejoin her well I just
[ __ ] here we'll have to guess in
[ __ ] purgatory like staring it marked
not playing at cards nothing said skip
marks this game's over [ __ ] because
haha alright it's [ __ ] because Wade
I think has like cheats to click the uno
button before it pops up so he's a he's
an [ __ ] that way he's a bad boy is
what I'm saying here Oh what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] no I was
gonna make you win wait I was gonna make
you win not anymore not with this hand
no I wanna go play with Bob let's go
let's back out let's go play bar okay
I'm gonna come over where you guys are
I think Wade let a horse head Looney
Toons wait my god those crashing who
knows completely completely well I gotta
pee again were you laughing and trying
to be quiet and sound this is the Rayman
deck by the way
Rayman aren't rabbits from the Rayman
universe I don't know I never played a
Rayman games on tape isn't it Rayman
dreaming Rabbids Raymond gram Bob I'm
not used to you being over on the right
this just Ivy I thought it's [ __ ]
mark thank thank you thank me first I
didn't have the game up guys guys I
didn't have the game up again I mean
yeah and listen the game is not that
important everybody the game is not that
important mark don't win I don't think
she asked read maybe luck do you exist
in oh yeah be [ __ ] kidding me no okay
I'll take that two can play this game I
know you were trying to press it I know
you were I know you were I knew you were
was it me how many cards do I have
you'll never know never mind
yeah yeah you'll never know what you
didn't know what it was then don't act
like you don't know I forgot it what
that was Bob calm down Wow
Barbara you [ __ ] what you doing
behind that cloud way in the world this
Barbara get it on the first try and well
bag look [ __ ] drawing board I think
Wade one screen well lick my anus and
call me Joseph Joe somebody great
I'm really sorry mark I didn't mean
you're not sorry at all
sorry you're not sorry
that's hardly like damn you damn you we
were done talking the time for talk is
over
[Music]
[Laughter]
Barbara you asked why did Barbara do you
have some issues you need to work
through man yes I knew I didn't trust
Barbara at all she's done is prove me
right oh [ __ ] you Barbara I think
Barbara's pretty cool I got nothing
Barbara Jay seems awesome I like her
yeah Barbara neat well I like Barbara
what neat thing is she done no no she
looks cool she's got a hat I like cats I
like it to play now you know [ __ ]
[ __ ]
Oh exchange to me and now I have oh
that's not good oh don't you bärbel me
I'm coming
oh yeah baby thank you [ __ ] ah way do
you seem to think that everybody's out
to get ya me too
I got 14 [ __ ] everything Markham
tomorrow man yeah it's me it's me baby
Oh Barbara you sure you don't want to
stick it mining out whatever all right
how about one of these not yellow you
know even if you said not well I would
not listen
[Music]
[Music]
pasen tomorrow not bad yeah come on man
we're all having a friendly game we're
thanking each other we're [ __ ] each
other
it's a long oh that one back sure go for
it you're gonna undo what I just go for
this one right next to me again what's
wrong with that one we're not doing
anything whirring Bob and I are having a
perfectly normal game of normal every
other turn with you okay yeah so I've
had some bad luck I'm down on my luck
today you don't kick a man while he's
down on his lucky good lady luck I'm
gonna win now look at that whoo that's a
special one oh yeah I don't know what
does that do oh it changes the color Wow
thank you okay do not do anything maybe
it's like oh it's a defense card okay
okay
[ __ ] you everything green is pretty cool
yeah great school Barbara don't Bluff
Barbara no Bluff okay all right how
about one of these ooh that's pretty
good that's pretty good oh never mind
hey wait no no you don't have to do that
[Music]
to play see wait that happened
oh come on now ma'am that's fine well
that's not good you don't know it's not
good wait you see we all know who the
enemy is here who's I don't know what
color I don't know what color you want
clearly hope you're not talking about me
baby it's fine just leave it okay I
click the button but I was a second late
god damn everything not I got a frog I
got so that's not what that doesn't help
me
all right listen you not helping me
I think ah perfect
oh I forgot my memory not real good like
I can't Barbara I think is the worst
done nothing to you I don't know what
that does you know here it is okay all
right why do you and that really panned
out fun with your sevens wait I just I
just Tom Sawyer the [ __ ] out of you Hank
Sawyer yeah yeah damn it Tom Sawyer
ankle bear oh well that's not fun no I
think you're right the first
henkle Barry wait get your revenge on
the Barbara oh I did [ __ ] you barb
yeah thank [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] thank
you oh thank you thank you
ah okay Oh
wowie wow wow wow my turn again what a
play
Bob the real it's a real winner I got
there it's better than the winner I
don't why it is oh god no I don't but I
think one of the great green oh yeah
greats a good color at least the sevens
are going away no oh no hi yeah happy
whistling is pissing me off who's
whistling no one's whistling music in
the game I don't hear any wait listen
wait some people are genetically gift
like hands that's me I'm one of them
lucky need no no say you did this to
Farber yourself
call buddy why would you let do that
happen it's already punished this bugs
out on a goddamn green nevermind I was
kidding
I think that's what kidding means that's
a nice troop train that's not true Cole
you're right you're right nice troop
allege Hank Hill and troop well yeah
you're right you're on fire my favorite
possibly play any of these I'm gonna
keep them cuz you're [ __ ] nothin to
you Bob yeah you just did all of that to
me no one did anything to you I don't
think alright I don't think it was
Barbara I'm just like all of you Martin
we were on the same side of the fence
and now you're like the gate you don't
even know what side of the fence I'm on
Wade
oh I do because you're flashing your
cloak II underwear around while yours
walk we don't have cloak underwear yet
oh well I guess that you're on the
inside and everyone else the outside yes
I don't know man what are you talking
about yeah you know no I don't know Bob
help hey I hate all of you
[Music]
yeah Oh everything well it's gonna go
ahead and do that yeah that's good one
that's a good one that's a good one all
right you're so eager you're Marmara
anything but me anyone by me
reverse No Bogut's oh you can all ball
no get your [ __ ] selves Barbara oh
that's not it that's not good
Barbara Barbara has two yellows wave
you're gonna have to do something about
this Barbara's gonna win again
wait fix it I could have fixed it I
could have fixed well this game
we've lost twice to a shitty AI actually
stop I don't know why this game makes me
so angry I don't know we're having a
great time I'm actually I am actually
having a good time oh that's because I'm
suffering whatever what someone
suffering everyone else has yeah
whatever that sound was yeah that's the
stuff it was a mark sniff sniff I went
that wasn't the noise why Hey look the
only card I had man that's okay yes II
to [ __ ] you just happens stop actually
[ __ ] me mark
can we start intentionally [ __ ] bar
off
for a barbers done everything oh thanks
bro look at that sweet hand oh no really
your friend no hey no this is a bunch of
a scream and I don't like it no you
don't even know a scream god damn it
good block that I really blocked down oh
good blocked it up real good
well that's rude it's not rude I feel
like that was unnecessary it was totally
necessary oh that's not good Oh Barbara
course Barbara you're right Barbara's
not as bad as I thought
oh that's not the button I'm a boy
that's why I guess oh well that's not
right not the button I meant to push Oh
Oh baby baby baby baby oh yes well for a
minute here how are you doing mark I'm
good yeah good having a fun friendly
game lots of fun lots of friendliness
friends I'm not too worried about
winning or losing me neither
I guarantee you he has no [ __ ] idea
how to unmute himself oh wait I didn't
do anything
oh that's right I did it yeah sorry mark
I'm really sorry
the cards you know I don't think you're
rude I don't think you're sorry I didn't
have anything else I could have done in
that situation you know give me your
cards give you a card that's fun with
the red four and the blue for hey Wayne
oh my secrets I know what color they are
I have some solutions to this problem
wait I I for one I for one have an
eidetic memory and I know for a fact
[ __ ] well don't worry because I've been
planning things hey Barbara hang out I
told you Barbara's not in it for us
she's in it for yourself what you're
down with though would you
Hey everywhere oh hey everyone just
could take a woah
we're all friends here man wait you
really messed up you shouldn't have done
what no no thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you as we all know who
knows based entirely on skill I think
greedy [ __ ] take it my head I read
the most beautiful time okaywe listen I
agree marked it really well thank you do
you have any nice things to say about
Mark Waid I've seen shorter people turn
again you put me on the spot to have a
good time way just relax
[Laughter]
[Music]
nobody pal buddy pal our buddy palette I
don't know I'm not buddy Palin to you on
buddy pounds good [ __ ] with your booty
guards I could ruin this like oh wait is
so hot and cold with the whole teamwork
thing Gotham is cheating teamwork
against everyone else is fine I don't
think that's how team work works say the
big old dick somebody tell me what's the
stick I had a point stuff I don't one we
gotta worry about mark your cards are
hidden in the fog we know you only have
one Oh true oh you have no idea how many
I have I didn't
I didn't mean that buddy oh thank god
your fog wall with down low enough for
us to see you only have to thank you I
wish I had a fog wall jealous of your
fog mark thanks man everybody is
everybody is watch this and
flesh-colored took me a while to grow
this fog I like how Fletcher's above all
else I call good you asked people on the
phone calls I call good oh that's a
tasty one there buddy Oh taste this
okay it's a little room done all right
that's pretty aggressive oh no oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] I gifted that to you wait I gifted
that to you okay all right okay
oh well I know what color you have Bob I
know I don't think you do I know I know
I know
uh-huh cuz he doesn't have that color
yeah I don't know what color Wade has
though oh oh it's so anticlimactic when
somebody with
it's a little early to be tossing these
around but I guess wait what's your in
look like yeah pretty I got a fire a
nice thing going on here I see what
you're going for
sure do Oh sack bean okay
hey there we go that's a good one oh
[Music]
it's just gonna be the most casual and
game ever if someone's gonna waited like
20 turns I think Barbara deserves
another turn probably needs to cut out
some cards there that's rude I don't
think it's ending your goddamn business
with Barbara does Jesus fine I'm sorry I
think you stay out of Barbara's [ __ ]
business and mind your own self I just
wonder to hope though you know friendly
lick your own ass
I'm trying ly hard to win right now no
that's not what I wanted you to do to
light did it I did the thing without
their mark who knows I don't know you
know no wait hang on oh that's rude okay
oh hey that's the wrong way no no it's
not the wrong way cuz I got this going
on
oh yeah part of the car Barbara really
[ __ ] it up alright that's not right
whoa hey calm the [ __ ] down
they say well I'm never gonna get rid of
either of these goddamn cards it's Auto
play greens a bad color well this is
awkward
oh hey yeah well I appreciate the
sentiment I guess but Molly when you're
buying gifts for people who that's
[Laughter]
interested
okay Oh got it whoa you sure got it all
right oh hey how do I have all these
cards and nothing to play what is this
these guys oh geez everything's going
well for everyone yeah yeah me too
Barbara that's what you get for treating
me like [ __ ] all day Barbara has done
nothing to use Claire well thanks buddy
I appreciate that cards I don't
yellow is a dick pea color dick P what
other kind of P is there a dick feed
color
oh [ __ ] you just got to do it again
Barbara do it do it some more Barbara
[ __ ] I'm talking about Barbara
Barbara Barbara could lick a taint
Barbara could you know who hasn't been
an unbelievable grumpus this whole day
Barbara just sitting up there grinning
missing that tooth but it's cool truth
look at this Barbara roof she's giving
the stink eye because she hates us and
she hates happiness look at that face
that you have in your profile picture
yeah I'm excited to be here hey Mark
yes I'm gonna believe in the heart of
the cards so you know you want to and
you know why you want to because you
want this to happen god yeah
[Applause]
heart of the cards I'm so hard right now
for hard my heart and my cards I have a
good card to play I do and I'm just
thinking just thinking real hard about
that and and something will come up I
have to pee again
[Laughter]
went to a personal trainer for the first
time yesterday and he said my my water
weight I'm 5 percent dehydrated like 5
percent less of my body weight of water
I don't have why would you do that mark
I set you up for that what [ __ ] is
happening whose turn is it ok well you
know I like this garden I'm just gonna
keep it there we go
hi-yah I like I don't remember I think
we're safe with this I think I'm
quitting out as well I'm quitting
I can't Ulta for this game fast enough
[Music]